Este martes decenas de miles de
trabajadores del Distrito Escolar
unificado de Los Ángeles iniciaron una
huelga de tres días el motivo el escaso
avance de las negociaciones paritarias
los dos gremios más importantes del
distrito se unieron para reclamar
mejores condiciones laborales y mayor
personal en el segundo sistema escolar
más grande de Estados Unidos
[Aplausos]
son los compañeros de trabajo que son
los trabajadores peor pagados en
nuestras escuelas y no podemos quedarnos
de brazos cruzados ya que constantemente
Los vemos y respetados y maltratados por
este distrito
bajo la lluvia se desarrolló la primera
protesta de trabajadores protagonizada
principalmente por maestros pero que
también incluyó ayudantes consejeros
miembros de educación especial
transportistas y conserjes entre otros
los sindicatos exigen Un aumento al 30%
y alegan que algunos trabajadores de la
comunidad educativa están por debajo de
la línea de la pobreza y luchan contra
la inflación y el alto costo de vida en
Los Ángeles
tenemos que hacerles saber que estamos
aquí por respeto y que no nos vamos a
conformar con nada menos que eso Este es
una huelga de tres días pero puede
convertirse en algo más grande si es
necesario
el sistema educativo de Los Ángeles
alberga a medio millón de estudiantes
locales y engloba la mayor parte de los
jóvenes de 25 ciudades aledañas de los
cuales tres cuartas partes son latinos